[Musique]
bonjour depuis le 16 juin les députés de
la commission d' enquête consacrée à
l'épidémie de kobe de 19 auditionne des
acteurs de la crise sanitaire monde
médical mais aussi ancien ministre et
directeur généraux de la santé tout
l'été lcp vous fait revivre ces
auditions aujourd'hui celle de william
dab à la tête de la direction générale
de la santé de 2003 à 2005
il est considéré comme l'un des plus
grands spécialistes français des
questions liées à la sécurité sanitaire
voilà son analyse de la gestion de la
crise de koffi 19 je tiens d'abord
monsieur le professeur à vous remercier
bien sûr de votre présence je rappelle
que parmi les nombreuses fonctions que
vous avez exercé vous avez été directeur
général de la santé de 2003 à 2005 après
avoir été conseiller technique
responsable du pôle santé publique et
sécurité sanitaire au cabinet du
ministre de la santé jean françois
mattei
c'est à cette période en 2004 qu'a été
élaboré le premier plan gouvernemental
de lutte contre la pandémie grippale
dans le cadre de la menace de grippe
aviaire à chaque et n 2004 2005
vous vous êtes souvent exprimé au cours
des dernières semaines
je souhaiterais que nous abordions au
cours de cette audition les principales
conclusions auxquelles vous êtes
parvenus
votre analyse de ce qu'il serait
nécessaire de développer pour être mieux
préparé plus efficace en matière de
prévention et de santé publique
enfin je précise que vous avez été
chargé par la ministre de l'outre-mer
madame annick girardin et par le
ministre des solidarités de la santé
olivier ferrand d'une mission d'appui à
l'agencé régionale de santé sous le co
vite 19 à mayotte territoire qui est
toujours dans une situation sanitaire
extrêmement difficile je souhaiterais
que nous abordions évidemment ce point
également
avant de vous donner la parole je vais
vous demander de prêter serment
en effet l'article 6 de l'ordonance du
17 novembre 1958 relative au
fonctionnement des assemblées
parlementaires impose aux personnes
auditionnées par une commission denquête
de prêter serment de dire la vérité
toute la vérité rien que la vérité
je vous invite donc à lever la main
droite
et à dire je le jure merci je rappelle
que cette audition et public
elle est donc diffusé en direct
consultable en vidéo et fera l'objet
d'un compte rendu écrit monsieur vous
avez la parole merci de votre accueil
madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les députés
bien sûr il nous faut réfléchir ce qui
s'est passé ce qui peut encore se passer
pourquoi n'étions nous pas mieux
préparés alors que je dirais que la
pandémie était inévitable
ça va faire plaisir à mon éditeur joue
le monde quand même
j'en suis à la cinquième édition du que
sais-je santé environnement à chaque
fois il y avait un chapitre sur le les
risques de pandémie dans la dernière
édition qui est sorti en début d'année
en janvier ce chapitre avait encore été
augmenté
je suis évidemment pas du tout le seul à
avoir évoqué cette cette perspective il
y a bien sûr des aspects conjoncturels
pourquoi n'étions nous pas mieux équipés
en masques en test au gel je vais pas
pouvoir vous aider beaucoup là dessus il
y à une reconstitution des décisions
publiques à faire mais au-delà de ça je
crois qu'il ya vraiment des raisons
structurelles
jeux jeux centrerait mon intervention
sur ce point il y as pour moi deux
raisons structurelles qui s'additionnent
la première c'est la faiblesse de la
santé publique du domaine de la santé
publique dans notre pays et la seconde
c'est une vision comptable des missions
de l'état sur la faiblesse de la santé
publique ce ça demande une analyse
historique qui serait très longue
affaire je pourrais vous envoyer des
documents des articles si vous voulez il
ya eu beaucoup de travaux
là dessus je me contenterai de vous
rappeler que dans la structure des
dépenses nationales de santé
chaque fois que nous en dépensons 196
vos soins individuels 4 euros vont à la
prévention organisée c'est donc un
déséquilibre très fort évidemment ce
sera jamais ça comme 50 ce serait
ridicule mais je dirais que les pays à
fortes santé publique sont plutôt sur un
ratio de 90 10 en france la santé
publique a toujours été pris comme un
secteur purement administratif et sans
valeur ajoutée un certain nombre de mots
clés pour illustrer ce propos
chlordécone un dossier sur lequel j'ai
également beaucoup travaillé un
pesticide utilisé dans l'est dans les
bananeraies des antilles françaises
le médiator avec un procès actuellement
vous vous rappelez du levothyrox où vous
rappelez de la sphère lactalis vous vous
vous connaissez les débats actuels sur
la toxicité du glyphosate
on a vu en septembre dernier un certain
nombre de difficultés dans la gestion de
l'incendié de lubrizol
on a vu également qu'il était difficile
de gérer des problèmes comme les bébés
sans bras et il ya des points communs
entre tout cela c'est que si nous
disposons aujourd'hui ce qui n'a pas
toujours été le cas mais nous l'avons
aujourd'hui d'une expertise de santé
publique on peut qualifier de bonn qui
correspond au rang kaka notre pays en
matière de matières scientifiques
en revanche nous avons une grande
faiblesse des forces de santé publique
sur le terrain et à chaque fois c'est là
que nous avons eu des difficultés
rencontrons des difficultés de gestion
un autre signe de cela vous avez rappelé
le travail que que j'ai fait comme
conseiller de jean françois mattei qui
m'avait fait venir au à son cabinet pour
préparer une loi de santé publique y en
avait une en 1902 il y en a une autre en
2004 je voudrais rappeler à la
représentation nationale que sur un
amendement parlementaire
cette loi avait prévu que la politique
de santé publique du pays soit discutée
au parlement tous les cinq ans c'était
un amendement parlementaire le ministre
m'avait dit qu'il y croyait pas trop
mais en même temps 10 amis s'ils le font
c'est vraiment une bonne chose et donc
avec l'accord du gouvernement cet
amendement a été voté il n'a jamais été
appliqué
qu'est ce que cela signifie ça signifie
qu'on s'intéresse à la santé publique en
temps de crise mais qu'en temps de paix
on l'oubli
j'en viens et c'est lié à ce que je
ressens comme étant la vision comptable
des missions de l'état
vous avez reçu le docteur baudillon il
vous a expliqué que santé publique
france a perdu 20% de ces postes
j'ai regarder ça de très près parce qu'à
la demande du docteur bourdillon j'ai
fait une mission près de santé publique
france qui a permis d'organiser la
fusion des départements santé travail et
département santé environnement et je
m'étais penché à l'époque il ya deux ans
sur les ressources dont dispose et santé
publique france les ressources ont
diminué mais les missions sont restés
les mêmes donc on a un pilotage par les
moyens on n'a pas un pilotage par les
objectifs et dans l'appareil d'état
il ya très peu de réflexion sur
l'adéquation entre les missions et les
moyens
j'ai eu un grand espoir un moment donné
au moment de la lolf et comme directeur
général de la santé je m'étais porté
volontaire pour l'expérimenté c'est ce
qui a été fait et j'avais trouvé que
c'était vraiment un exercice très
intéressant qui nous avaient forcé à
proposer des objectifs de santé publique
des objectifs de sécurité sanitaire mais
j'ai l'impression que cette logique là a
été perdu en cours de route et qu'on a
un pilotage par les moyens plus que par
les objectifs
tout ça fait que collectivement nous
avons du mal à apprendre je trouve
il ya quand même eu beaucoup d' alerte
il ya eu le strass j'étais au cabinet du
ministre à l'époque il ya eu la menace
h1n1 il ya eu et bola la france a joué
un rôle quand même très important dans
la maîtrise de l'épidémie
sans remonter trop loin il ya eu la
vache folle etc
c'est comme si nous n'apprenons pas et
c'est aussi comme si nous avions eu
beaucoup de chance parce qu'à chaque
fois
après une phase de forte inquiétude soit
que la menace s'est révélée moins sévère
qu'anticipée soit qu'elles aient été
bien gérée comme dans le cas de l'ebola
et bien on est passé à autre chose
cette difficulté que notre système a à
apprendre et à faire des retours
d'expérience et je pense une des grandes
raisons 1 qui explique la situation dans
laquelle nous nous sommes retrouvés pour
terminer cette introduction je voudrais
quand même évoqué que bien sûr nous
regardons ça avec ce que nous savons
aujourd'hui mais tout au long de cette
affaire
je n'oublie pas que les responsables ont
fait face et font encore face à de très
nombreuses incertitudes
quelle est l'efficacité réelle des
masques quel est le potentiel de
mutation du virus
la saisonnalité la saison at elle un
effet sur sa virulence y at il une
transmission par aérosol et pas
seulement par les gouttelettes
est ce qu'il ya une immunité individuel
durable qu'en est-il de l'immunité
collective
quel est le rôle exact des enfants dans
le la dynamique de l'épidémie il n'y a
pas de réponse assurée à toutes ces
questions
je pourrais continuer longtemps c'est
pas exhaustif ce qui est sûr c'est qu'on
a compris assez vite je pense que les
épidémiologistes ont compris assez vite
sur la base de l'expérience chinoise que
cette épidémie était très hétérogène et
que ça n'avait rien à voir avec une
épidémie de grippe
et c'est d'ailleurs ça qui m'a conduit
un petit peu en fait à forcer ma nature
et intervenir dans les médias comme je
pense vous l'avez beaucoup entendu je
pense que présentait le coc vite 19
comme apparenté à l'épidémie de grippe
était une véritable erreur de diagnostic
et c'était assez évident sur la base de
l'expérience chinoise
deuxièmement dès qu'on a su qu'il y
avait une transmission
alors qu'on était prêts symptomatique ou
asymptomatiques pour un virus aussi
contagieux que celui là à transmission
aérienne la pandémie était inévitable
on ne peut pas éviter dans le monde
d'aujourd'hui un virus de sortir de
chine
même si l'épicentre est confiné dans ces
situations là on est toujours sous une
double une double menace d'en faire trop
ou pas assez bon nous avons fait les
deux on en a pas fait assez parce que
nous étions en déficit de capacité
d'action sur le terrain
je me suis exprimée plusieurs fois là
dessus mais c'était très frappant que
six semaines après le début du
confinement nous ayons encore plusieurs
milliers de patients hospitalisés chaque
jour et donc la question se pose est
quand même de savoir pour tous ces
patients c'était contaminés jeudi bien
six semaines après le confinement
j'en ai parlé au professeur chen la
directrice générale de santé publique
france mme dubé nous n'avons pas les
moyens
il ya trop de malades
nous ne pouvons pas investiguer les
sources de contagion est par ailleurs le
stade 3 du plan pandémie prévoit qu'on
arrête de faire ce travail
sauf que justement c'était pas un plan
de pandémie grippale
le modèle logique était de partir du
plan de pandémie grippale mais mais il
fallait l'adapter aux particularités de
ce coronavirus et de cette maladie qui
n'est pas la grippe est par ailleurs je
crois qu'on en a trop fait parce que si
l'objectif du confinement était de
soulager les tensions hospitalières
alors il était logique de le faire dans
trois régions mais pas dans les 24
autres
tout ça est difficile un jeu il faut
vraiment réalisé que prendre ces
décisions là en situation réelle et
difficile ce que je dirais c'est qu'il
faut vraiment une
une grande réactivité
constat j'étais pas là au coeur de
l'appareil d'état mais mon constat s'est
clos oms déclenché l'urgence de santé
publique de portée internationale le 30
janvier et que jusqu'au 16 mars
il ne sait quand même pas passé grand
chose dans notre pays et donc ce que
tout ça veut dire et vous m'avez
sûrement entendu l'affirmé à plusieurs
reprises
c'est à quel point nous avons été
remarquable et excellent dans le domaine
des soins ce qui a été fait par
l'ensemble de la communauté
dix soignants est absolument remarquable
je pense que nous sommes un des pays où
il ya eu le moins de perte de chance en
revanche en ce qui concerne la
prévention là je crois qu'il nous faut
rebâtir beaucoup de choses voilà ce que
je voulais vous dire en introduction je
suis évidemment à votre disposition pour
répondre à vos questions
j'ai vu vos déclarations vous l'évoquez
vous même à l'instant dans dans la
presse je vous cite vous indiquez je vis
une situation de défaite terrible de la
santé publique où l'avait un peu un peu
rappelé vous avez pointé l'absence d'un
maréchal en chef pour mener ce combat
inédit vous avez dit c'est la première
fois que l'on est en mesure de vaincre
une pandémie et pourtant regardez ce qui
se passe
vous indiquez qu'en matière de
prévention vous venez largement de le
rappeler nous ne sommes pas la hauteur
de l'épidémie et vous avez indique
également que le confinement aura plus
d'inconvénients économiques
psychologiques familiaux médicaux que de
bénéfices moi je voudrais vous
interroger ce qui nous motive
bien sûr c'est le constat je crois qu'il
doit laisser notre devoir au bout de ce
qui n'a pas fonctionné mais notre souci
dans l'hypothèse le conseil scientifique
a émis un avis aujourd'hui ou hier il
nous l'avait indiqué ici même la semaine
dernière sur la probabilité de rebond
d'une seconde vague en fonction de la
saisonnalité en octobre prochain
qu'est ce qu'il faudrait faire un
urgence à court terme puisque octobre
c'est le court terme pour être mieux
préparé et qu'est ce qu'il faut faire
selon-vous selon votre vision et
n'oublions pas que vous avez été un des
rédacteurs du plan pandémie en 2000 en
2004 2005 et donc pour vous quel
pilotage de la santé publique
aujourd'hui serait le plus pertinent
je crois que vous avez pointé la
multiple est-ce que la multiplicité des
organismes des institutions qui ont été
mobilisés dans la crise le groupe
conseil scientifique le caire qui se
rajoute à la haute autorité de santé à
des institutions scientifiques au chorus
est ce que tout cela ne fait pas une
accumulation d'instance qu'il est
difficile de coordonner bon et on
revient sur la question du pilotage pour
vous vous avez pointé ce déficit de
pilotage sans doute plus centralisée
enfin je vous ai vu à réclamer à la fois
un état stratège plus jacobin un état
plus girondins dans sa mise en oeuvre
des actions pour vous quel serait
l'organisation optimale et qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire là pour être prêt si
malheureusement et on doit travailler
sur cette hypothèse on a
une deuxième vague à l'automne
premièrement je crois qu'on a beaucoup
appris et la séquence diagnostiqué
traçage des contacts isolement gestes
barrières là je pense qu'elle est
elle est organisée elle et je pense
comprise par la population et elle est
mise en oeuvre
c'est toute la différence cette épidémie
est hétérogène regard regarder d'où elle
est partie à chaque fois c'était des
lieux clos avec beaucoup de gens
mulhouse la base de creil l'assemblée
nationale
les soignants qui ont été contaminés et
qui ont contaminé le porte avions
charles de gaulle
donc on sait ça maintenant
ce qu'on ne savait pas forcément au mois
de janvier il faut pas l'oublier et donc
on sait la cartographie des situations
qu'il faut surveiller très attentivement
il faut pouvoir mobiliser les forces de
terrain alors là il faudra voir je n'ai
pas la réponse si les 4000 agents de la
sécurité sociale seront encore
mobilisables à l'automne parce que l'on
peut imaginer qu'il n'est pas forcément
que ça à faire donc là il ya peut-être
une urgence qui fera le traçage des
contacts exactement mais ça c'est
fondamental
je vous reparlerai de mayotte tout à
l'heure c'est fondamental si on ne fait
pas ça on ne peut pas maîtriser
l'épidémie
donc on a appris ça c'est un facteur
énorme et donc si on s'organise bien si
on surveille qu'on diagnostique qu'on
dise hall dans des conditions correctes
et qu'on fait un traçage cette épidémie
est maîtrisable
après il ya la question du commandement
maréchal oui peut-être je sais pas ce
qui est absolument sûr tous ceux qui ont
eu l'expérience de par exemple d'ebola
beaucoup de gens et écouter la vidéo de
bill gates qui tirait les leçons de
l'épidémie d'ebola il a écrit un
remarquable et nico rial dans new
england journal of medicine
le commandement unifié est une condition
du succès pour que l'ensemble des forces
soient non pas mise au pas mais soient
coordonnés donc il ya une difficulté qui
est à la fois d'organiser la verticalité
et l'horizontalité
quand j'ai été interrogée par la mission
d'information du sénat
on est à distance à vos collègues
sénatrices et sénateurs
je me suis permis de leur poser la
question de faire un tour de table quand
leur posant la question à votre avis qui
est actuellement responsable dans notre
pays de la lutte contre l'épidémie
j'ai eu à peu près autant de réponses
qu'il y avait deux sénateurs connectés
je ne dis pas que ça ne marchait pas
mais je dis que quand y compris la
représentation nationale n'a pas une
vision claire de qui a la responsabilité
de quoi c'est un problème
la multiplicité des intervenants n'est
pas une difficulté en soit si chacun est
clair sur ses missions
et si on si on n'organise correct si on
organise la circulation la circulation
de l'information
évidemment tout émane du chef de l'état
n'y a aucun doute là dessus mes roues
mais on voit bien que face à un
événement où les conséquences sanitaires
sont aussi potentiellement préoccupante
que les conséquences sociales et que les
conséquences économiques
il faut il faut un pilotage un pilotage
unifié
il ya vraiment deux situations à
distinguer un oeil à la situation
je dirais froide habituel et il ya la
situation les situations d'urgence et
notamment d'urgence de sécurité
sanitaire moi je n'est là qu'une petite
expérience qu'est celle de mayotte où là
j'ai vraiment vu pendant 12 jours
comment comment ça se passait je pense
qu'entre l'agencé régionale de santé et
le préfet il ya des clarifications à
faire je ne sais pas ce que j'imagine
qu'il ya des régions françaises où ça
s'est bien passé sur mon jeu sans aucun
doute il ya des régions où ça a été plus
difficile un bilan serait très utile en
situation d'urgence
cette dualité régional ne me semble pas
une bonne chose alors on peut toujours
compter sur l'intelligence des hommes et
des femmes mais construire une politique
là dessus c'est évidemment prendre un
risque
je dis pas qu'elles n'existent pas
évidemment le plus souvent elles
existent mais ce n'est pas ce n'est pas
toujours le cas
donc je pense qu'il faut d'abord il faut
se mettre je crois résolument dans un
état d'esprit où il est impossible de
confier notre pays c'est impossible
il faut admettre que comme les chinois
sont en train de le faire comme les
allemands sont en train de le faire
déconfinement cible est localisée seront
nécessaires il faut les organiser le
mieux possible il faut être absolument
certain que nous aurons les capacités de
test et pas seulement pour tester les
symptomatique
mais également les contacts
asymptomatiques qu'on a longtemps pas pu
faire en france est une des causes de la
dynamique de l'épidémie dans d'autres
pays
faut pouvoir accompagner le confinement
dans toutes ses dimensions du tri sion
éducation des enfants isolement sa
demande d'une grande capacité logistique
et si nous faisons ça je pense je ne je
n'aime pas l'expression de deuxième
vague c'est pas le bon modèle le bon
modèle c'est que nous aurons des
dizaines de clusters à gérer en même
temps c'est pas une vague cédé points
d'attac j'ai utilisé le mot de guérilla
cédé points d'attac qui peuvent survenir
de façon hétérogène sur le territoire
c'est à ça qu'il faut se préparer
quant à renforcer nos capacités de santé
publique de terrain c'est un faisable
d'ici cet automne
je pense qu'il est urgent de lancer un
très grand plan de formation de
professionnels de santé publique
l'école des hautes études en santé
publique et par la loi de 2004 et je
pense en mesure d'y participer
grandement
d'autres d'autres établissements
d'enseignement supérieur est également
ce plan n'est pas compliqué à faire il
et il me semble urgent si nous prenons
des gens qui ont déjà une formation de
base dans le domaine de la santé
on peut les amener à devenir intervenant
santé publique en 18 mois 2 ans faut le
faire dès maintenant on peut pas rester
aussi démuni sur le terrain regardez le
nombre de médecins inspecteurs de santé
publique on a dans les ars
c'est pas possible c'est juste regarder
et regarder l'évolution des effectifs
c'est facile il suffit de prendre le plf
et vous allez les plf successifs vous
allez les retrouver rien ne coûte moins
cher que la prévention
mes collègues du cnam ou chiffrer le
coût global de confinement à 350
milliards d'euros par mois je pas
économiste mais j'ai pas vu que ce
chiffre avait été contestée par d'autres
analyses économiques ce qui nous fallait
comme moyen pour avoir un système de
prévention solide et sans commune mesure
avec ce que va coûter à notre pays ces
deux mois de conflit
merci je vais passer la parole à mes
collègues donc damien abad pour les
républicains
merci beaucoup madame la présidente sur
le directeur général simplement quelques
points et merci pour ces propos qui nous
éclairent effectivement beaucoup j'ai vu
comme d'autres que vous avez dit dans un
article
finalement la faute c'est bercy et vous
nous expliquer que en gros depuis 2013
mercier a dit non et notamment non
sur le stock de masques et le fait qu'on
ne faisait plus de masquer ma question
c'est il n'y a pas eu de changement de
doctrine depuis donc comment se fait-il
qu'un moment donné on se retrouve avec
un tel renversement est ce que vous
considérez que c'est un frein ou pas
l'organisation tel que nous l'avons
notamment dans la question de
souveraineté sanitaires et la gestion du
stock de masques
un deuxième point qui concerne les tests
vous avez déclaré à juste titre qu'il
fallait tester isolé protégez vous
l'avez dit aussi que le confinement
finalement faisait peser beaucoup
d'efforts sur la population et et que
donc on a manqué de test est-ce que là
dessus vous pouvez nous en dire plus
selon vous pourquoi on a tant manqué de
tests en france
pourquoi au moment où l'om est ce nous
d'y tester tester tester et vous dis
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure j'ai noté
entre le 30 janvier le 16 mars il se
passe pas grand chose dans notre pays et
c'est vrai quelles sont ses freins
pourquoi pourquoi la politique de test
n'a pas pu être plus développée
est-ce que c'est par corporatisme est ce
que ces partis ficultés bureaucratique
et c'est parce qu'il ya pas de pilote
dans l'avion est ce qu'il ya un manque
de décision politique chance que c'est
un point important sur la sur la
question des tests notamment et et la
question du strate traçage on a
aujourd'hui une application que
l'application stop qu'ovide quelle est
votre perception de sa pourquoi ça ne
fonctionne pas et est ce que vous pensez
qu'une telle application serait utile
alors j'ai bien entendu que de mou
deuxième vague été compliqué mais en
tout cas s'il y avait des recrudescences
de kloster voilà les trois
interrogations
merci beaucoup pour ces premiers
éléments pour prolonger les questions
qui ont été posées effectivement
s'agissant de la politique de test est
ce que vous avez une explication sur le
fait que l'institut pasteur met au point
un test pcr le 17 janvier et qu'en
réalité ils ne trouvent de l'effectivité
sur le terrain que très tard donc on a
du mal à comprendre ce lapse ce laps de
temps
première question deuxième question que
ce soit sur la façon dont on a été perçu
cette pandémie on a le sentiment qu'il
ya une controverse de médecins et de
scientifiques
certains y voyant un risque grave et
imminent d'autres relativisent ans
beaucoup la gravité de ce qui nous
menaçait et de la même manière on a vu
des conflits de crises par exemple
saisissante de l'usaj des masques on a
cru qu'on prend des auditions
précédentes qu' il y avait ceux qui
croyaient et ceux qui n'y croyaient pas
et que ceux qui n'y croyaient pas avait
peut-être fait le choix de ne pas
reconstituer les masques dont il ne
voyait pas l'utilité
ça c'est ma première question de
deuxième question vous avez évoqué la
question du commandement unifié et des
difficultés éventuelles entre les ars et
les préfets dans le commandement unifié
je voudrais savoir quelle est votre
appréciation de la création d'un conseil
scientifique un peu ado qu'au moment
plein coeur de la crise quelques jours
avant le confinement et comment vous
concevez son articulation avec santé
publique france ce qui évidemment on
peut se demander si on sous-estimé
l'importance que ça a apporté ce qu'on
sait scientifique mais de ce que ça a pu
apporter aussi peut-être de
perturbations voilà merci madame la
présidente monsieur merci de votre
présence professeur en ce moment donc il
y à quelques centaines de clusters sauf
que effectivement comme ça a déjà été
dit on a beaucoup appris et on sait
aujourd'hui détecter tester isolé
soigner si on avait pu faire ça dès le
début du mois de mars je vais dans le
sens de ce que je disais mon collègue
mon collègue abad est ce qu'on aurait pu
aller vers un confinement plus mesuré
plus modéré plus ciblées comme ça a été
le cas en allemagne
qu'est ce qui a manqué à la france au
delà des masques pour mettre en place un
confinement ciblées de ce type est ce
que les structures gouvernementales et
l'organisation de la santé allemande ont
su faire ce que nous n'avons pas réussi
en france et pour terminer entre 2005
quand vous avez quitté sa ferme à paris
la direction de la santé et aujourd'hui
il ya eu de grandes évolutions dans
l'organisation territoriale de la santé
en france
est ce qu'elle a démontré de son
efficacité ou pas sinon comment est ce
qu'on peut corriger pour améliorer
l'efficacité de ceux de cette
organisation territoriale je vous
remercie
merci je vais vous donner la parole pour
répondre déjà ces questions il y aura
beaucoup d'autres encore donc sur les
thèses je suis incapable de vous
répondre je n'ai pas les éléments
qu'est ce qui a manqué on a manqué de
tout de réactifs de deux tiges de
prélèvement
pourquoi je ne sais pas je n'ai pas
accès à ces informations
si sur le rôle de de bercy sur les
masses qui coûtait pour préparer cette
audition j'ai relu exhaustivement le
plan pandémie grippale kk etait bleui
par le premier ministre en 2005 juste au
moment où j'ai quitté la dgs je me
souviens parfaitement de la discussion
que nous avons eue sur les masques
j'avais un collègue britannique le chief
medical officer liam donaldson qui était
extrêmement compétent en santé publique
et que je lui parlais vraiment très
souvent il y a même expliqué que dans le
plan pandémie britannique il n'y aurait
pas de masque parce que l'efficacité des
masques n'était pas démontrée
et moi je lui disais c'est pas parce
qu'elle n'est pas démontré qu'elles
n'existent pas parce qu'en réalité
démontré l'efficacité d'un masque c'est
un peu compliqué sur le plan des c'est
impossible c'est un peu compliqué en
terme de protocole épidémiologique
mais on a on a quand même des
démonstrations chez les soignants que
des soignants protégés par des masques
ont des risques diminué d'un certain
nombre de transmissions de maladies
infectieuses et donc moi j'ai pris la
position que malgré l'incertitude il y
aurait des masques dans le plan pandémie
français
j'ai demandé à la sous-directrice de
faire l'évaluation du nombre de masse
nécessaire j'ai retrouvé sa note
elle m'avait dit 850 millions de masques
tous les soignants devant être équipés
en effet p2 et pour la population
générale nous avions écrit dans le plan
masque chirurgical ou masque en tissu
c'était en 2005
voilà est arrivée la pandémie sur lequel
mon successeur vous le savez a joué un
rôle très important comme délégué
interministériel ce qui m'a semblé à
l'époque est un bon modèle de
gouvernance déléguée interministérielle
à la grippe aviaire
voilà parce que le rôle interministériel
est indispensable dans ces affaires
complexes
ce que le dgs ne peut pas exercer ce que
les ars ne peuvent pas exercer la
formule du délégué interministériel
était était très bonne et didier houssin
je pense voilà très très bien travaillé
alors après bon vous connaissez
l'histoire trop de mastrad vaccins et
cetera bon bien sûr on a oui en 2009
2010 il ya eu un gaspillage par rapport
aux 700 milliards du confinement excusez
moi on n'est même pas dans l'épaisseur
du trait on est dans de cheveux donc il
faut savoir prendre des risques en
sécurité sanitaire il faut parfois
investir et quand on investit on gagne
on perd mais globalement quand on
investit en prévention on gagne donc il
faut pas changer comme ça sans arrêt un
coup ça marche pas je fais l'un vers 5
ou de sa marche continue faut une
continuité dans les politiques de
sécurité sanitaire on a baissé la garde
après la pandémie grippale qui a décidé
de ne pas renouveler le stock
stratégique de 1 milliard de masques je
ne sais pas il faut il faut aller
regarder il faut sortir les il faut
sortir les réunions interministérielles
il faut voir qui a signé
quelles décisions budgétaires il faut
regarder les projets de loi de finances
et regarder les lignes détaillé pour
voir ce qui est tout ça est traçable
mais il ya un travail d' enquêtes à
faire je peux pas le faire c'est pas à
moi de le faire
e
stop qu'ovide écoutez je vous dis très
franchement ce que j'en pense oui il ya
un intérêt épidémiologique
moi je ne suis pas prêt à tous les
sacrifices de liberté individuelle au
nom de la protection de la sécurité
sanitaire
je suis un ardent défenseur de la santé
j'ai passé ma carrière a essayé de
renforcer le secteur de la sécurité
sanitaire dans notre pays
je ne suis pas prêt à dire que ceci doit
être fait à n'importe quel prix
démocratiques
je pense que la solution qui a été
retenue dans notre pays est assez sage
de ce point de vue avec un coq avec des
points de vigilance démocratique qui
sont le bienvenu je n'ose imaginer ce
que donnerait ce genre d'application si
nous tombions sous des régimes
autoritaires
alors évidemment encore et ça a marché
très bien mais ça a marché parce que
c'était couplé à un système policier et
que si vous ne respectez pas le
confinement est bien la police venait
vous cherchez moi je veux pas ça
clairement je ne veux pas ça donc je
pense que si nous avons une bonne
épidémiologie de terrain nous ne sommes
pas obligés d'être intrusive dans la vie
privée des gens ou qu'on le sera dans le
cas d'un face à face qui respecte le
secret médical
mais confier ça à une boîte noire dont
on ne sait pas très bien ce qu'elle
recueille comme données qui ça va
quelles sont les capacités de piratage
et le couplage toujours possible ce que
l'on voit là pas moi qui vais vous dire
qu'il ya des menaces sur la démocratie
quand même eh bien je pense qu'il faut
faire très attention et que la sécurité
sanitaire ne peut pas tout permettre sur
l'organisation notamment du comité
scientifique comité scientifique a fait
un travail extraordinaire je jurerais il
faut vraiment réaliser à quel point ces
gens ont été sollicités globalement ce
qu'ils ont dit n'est pas sujet à
controverse
je ne vois pas en ayant lu toujours leur
avis où ils se seraient où ils se
seraient trompés on pourrait parler des
modèles et du rôle des modèles mais bon
il ya une tentation toujours dans ces
situations un petit peu de tension de
créer de nouvelles institutions de
nouveaux organismes
personnellement je pense qu'il faudrait
essayer de résister à cette tentation
il ya un certain nombre d'organismes
experts vous vous en avez cités il ya
quand même le haut conseil de la santé
publique
faut pas l'oublier l'académie de
médecine a fait un travail remarquable
j'aurais personnellement plutôt essayer
un comité de liaison comité de liaison
entre l'inserm le cnrs les académies pas
que l'académie de médecine pharmacie et
cetera le haut conseil de la santé
publique la haute autorité de santé
les présidents des conseils
scientifiques des agences puisque toutes
les agences sont dotés d'un conseil
scientifique
ceux ci auraient je crois permis de
donner une feuille de route à chacun des
organismes d'avoir une sorte de bureau
de coordination de l'expertisé voilà
personnellement j'aurais fait ça mais on
n'a pas à rougir je crois pas du tout de
ce que le conseil scientifique a fait
quand même
il me semble qu'en matière de pilotage
de la recherche sur le co vide là là je
pense que nous avons perdu en efficacité
et qu'en particulier le pilotage des
essais thérapeutiques n'a pas été
suffisamment fort que du coup il ya eu
des doublons que du coup on a manqué de
patience pour faire tous les essais
prévus
et là je pense qu'on recherche clinique
une coordination nationale de toutes les
de toutes les ressources possibles rêve
vraiment été aurait vraiment été
vraiment nécessaire
alors si nous avions eu des tests est ce
qu'on aurait évité le confinement si
nous avions fait ce que les allemands où
je vais je me répète tester isolement
cible y traçage des cas isolement suivi
14 n on aurait eu du confinement ciblées
et pas un confinement généralisée au
pays
aucun doute aucun doute là dessus
enfin l'efficacité territoriale alors ça
c'est une énorme question mais là à
nouveau
vraiment je m'adresse à la
représentation nationale dans la loi qui
a créé les ars l'ondam devait être
régionale i nous devions avoir d or dame
nous ne l'avons jamais eu
donc je suis désolé je m'en doute
donc vous comprenez quand on s'arrête au
milieu du chemin et qu'on dit nous
allons organiser territorialement les
soins et la prévention ce qu'il faut
faire
évidemment mais qu'on oublie les moyens
si j'ai envie de dire c'est un peu comme
d'habitude en france on pense avoir
résolu un problème quand on a écrit un
texte
et quand il s'agit d'en vérifier
l'effectivité sur le terrain il ya
pendant qu on manque de l'autre on voit
bien que on est arrivé au début de cette
crise avec peu de moyens un peu de
moyens de protection donc les questions
que vous posez nous nous les posons est
évidemment il faudra savoir exactement
d'où vient le fait d'avoir baissé autant
baisser autant la garde mais il ya quand
même une question que je me pose
on voit la crise arriver alors on la
voit certes par des signaux de l' oms
on la voit également par des images
notamment douanes
le confinement de one c'est sous mais si
mes souvenirs sont bons le 23 le 23
janvier 300 on rapatrie 300 français de
chine
et tout comme vous on observe que l'on
prend les décisions qu à partir
notamment de confinement à partir du 13
mars avant ça il ya quand même la crise
qui arrive en italie alors le professeur
delfraissy qui est une personnalité
vraiment très très bon niveau nous dit
mais moi même
j'apprends l'ampleur de la crise le 21
je crois février à une réunion à genève
la chine nous a menti peut-être
peut-être enfin est ce qu'on n'a pas il
n'y a quand même pas des signaux très
clairs
nous invitons en vraiment à une
mobilisation avant cette période du 13
mars
et vous comment vous avez perçu c'est
les les premières semaines de janvier
ce que vous pensez que on aurait pu ou
on aurait dû réagir plus tôt ce qui se
dégage du propos qui est le vôtre c'est
la nécessité de faire preuve de sang
froid
j'ai l'impression et de clarté
face à face à l'épreuve est-ce que vous
avez le sentiment que de ce point de vue
là les choses ont été gérées avec la
maîtrise nécessaire parce qu'évidemment
c'est bien que ça compte la
communication quand on veut affronter
des problèmes de cette ampleur deuxième
question sur la recherche
comment expliquer effectivement je
rejoindrai la question précédente
expliqué que nous n'ayons pas été en
mesure d'entendre les alertes celle là
votre sans doute vous avez cité au début
de votre propos mais celle aussi d'un
certain organismes cnrs pour ne pas le
citer et d'autres dans la dernière
regarde comment les choses peuvent se
connecter mieux pour que nous soyons
aussi en phase et que nous donnions les
moyens la recherche de nous permettre
d'anticiper aussi un certain nombre de
problèmes ça fait partie des politiques
de prévention
quel regard portez vous avez vous un
avis vous l'avez fleuret cette question
là sur le débat autour des traitements
effectivement des essais sur ces
traitements et la recherche
les essais cliniques des polémiques que
ça peut susciter et c'est tout troisième
question et je me suis mis dans ma faim
concernant la doctrine en matière de
tests parce que le sentiment qu'on a
eues avec les différentes phases les
trois phases
qui avait été déterminée c'est peut-être
au moment on a décidé de mettre un peu
les tests en sourdine aura au contraire
fallu les amplifier qu'est ce que vous
pouvez nous nous préciser là-dessus
enfin sur le démantèlement de l'eprus
fin son démantèlement et puis sa fusion
à l'intérieur de santé publique france
pour être plus précis est ce que vous
pensez qu'il n'y a pas là une fonction
particulière que nous devrions préserver
et question corollaire et la dernière
sur la gestion des stocks dans pour les
personnels des stocks de masques pour
les personnels dans les établissements
est ce que il n'ya pas là aussi quelque
chose qui nous a conduits à être en
difficulté finalement dans cette
décision là comme vous avez un peu
d'historique sur la matière autre
éclairage tout serait pas mieux
tout d'abord vous évoquiez la première
épidémie de sras ce en 2002 qui était un
coronavirus également quels
enseignements at on tiré de cette
épidémie de 2,2 coronavirus deux
premiers chronos riche mais c'était même
si ce n'est pas le même ensuite je
souhaitais vous interrogé également sur
la situation de 2003 une crise assez
complexe avec la canicule
on se rappelle tous de l'appel d'un
médecin du professeur pelouse de les
chiffres publiés par l'inserm à plus de
19000 mort du manque de matériel c'était
du matériel les ventilateurs des choses
comme ça mais dans les suites on a eu
des pièces rafraîchies at il eu des
moyens qui ont été mis en place des
organisations qui ont été mis en place
des enseignements qui ont été tirées de
cette rude crise ça y est d'ailleurs
serions nous prêts aujourd'hui en cas de
canicule et on a bien vu
là encore la fragilité d'un public
particulier c'est à dire celui des
personnes âgées
en 2004 on a eu l'acte
juridique le plan blanc qui a été actée
juridiquement et la question qui se pose
c'est est-ce que c'était plutôt une
réponse à un risque d'infection des
soignés at-on vraiment pris en compte la
protection des soignants dans ses plans
blancs d'ailleurs pouvait nous vous
pouvez vous nous éclairer sur votre
vision de la doctrine stock tactique
stocks stratégiques des éléments de ces
équipements de 2,2 de protection et je
voulais juste vous vous interrogez très
précisément aussi vous parlais tout à
l'heure des ffp2 pour tous les soignants
les deux de dgs que nous on a deux
anciennes gs conditionné nous ont dit
les faits pde était uniquement pour les
anesthésistes anesthésistes pneumologue
c'est ce qu'ils nous ont dit donc et
répété quatrième question votre avis sur
le des confidents vous nous avez déjà
parlé vous parliez après la
problématique de confinement ciblé alors
c'est vrai que le confinement reste
quand même manifestement primordial une
des premières précautions à prendre
puisque on voit que même dans les pays
comme la chine où on avait des masses
puisqu'ils sont protecteurs ils ont
confiné
ils sont producteurs pendant mais ils
ont confiné on a vu des images ce week
end de confinement très localisées en
allemagne avec des quartiers à en fermer
complètement
quelle est votre vision là dessus et je
fais le parallèle avec le conseil
scientifique on a bien vu avec le
professeur delfraissy qu'il y avait une
volonté aussi éthique sociale sociétale
d'un abord transversale qui pouvait
avoir à mon avis et je vous pose la
question aussi cette vision parce que on
voit bien qu'il ya un problème de
l'acceptabilité d'une décision et puis
une dernière question je vous ai entendu
parler de l'ondam territorialisées est
ce que vous ne pensez pas que ça aurait
eu un impact avec une décentralisation
massif qui a été justement remise en
question lors de l'épidémie l'arrivée
d'épidémie en italie où on a plutôt dit
que la décentralisation justement et la
régionalisation du système de santé
italien avait été
péjorative versus la centralisation
française merci
plusieurs questions je reviendrai sur
celle de la gouvernance
on a évoqué la gouvernance vous l'avez
évoqué tout à l'heure la gouvernance
territoriale et vous citiez très
justement au niveau national l'intérêt
de la transversalité et d'un délégué
interministériel là il y avait à la fois
le conseil scientifique qui était qui
étaient à l'oeuvre les différentes
agences et sauf erreur il y avait
différentes cellules de crise à l'elysée
à matignon à la direction générale de la
santé et à la djs et est il normal qu'il
y ait autant de cellule de crise qui en
plus vraisemblablement ne connut
communiqué pas suffisamment entre elles
ça c'était la première question
deuxième question vous avez très
justement évoqué l'allemagne étant élu
en alsace l'alsace est la région la plus
touchée au départ et elle est restée
pendant plusieurs semaines une véritable
problématique en effet concernant le
confinement concernant le dépistage mais
également concernant le traitement
vous avez mis en avant les soignants et
je vous en remercie parce que les
soignants ou et des remarquables mais il
y avait une saturation totale des
hôpitaux
ne pensez-vous pas que nous ne sommes
pas suffisamment appuyée sur les
médecins libéraux les médecins de
première ligne qui ont quelque part ont
été écartés à la fois du soin à la fois
du dépistage et là encore dans les
équipes les brigades de la sécurité
sociale en allemagne ce sont les
allemands qui les pardons en allemagne
ce sont les médecins traitants qui font
cette activité là ils n'ont pas de
brigade spécifiques que pensez vous d'un
tel système qui manifestement paraît
beaucoup plus efficient je ne reviendrai
pas non plus
mais c'est vrai qu'on ne vous n'avez pas
du tout abordé la question de la de la
terra qui votre avis sur le fait qu'on a
empêché les médecins libéraux d'utiliser
certaines molécules donc ils n'ont pas
été libres de leurs prescriptions bon
est ce qu'on aurait pu réagir plus tôt
oui bon je joue je vois la jolie dit il
il y à une leçon à tirer je crois pour
vraiment tout le monde je les jeux les
souvent noté et d'ailleurs nous l'avons
vu de façon quasi caricatural au moment
de lubrizol d'un incendie de l'usiné en
situation d'incertitude il y à un
réflexe premier qui est de rassurer la
population
donc on comprend mieux pourquoi c'est
complètement humains vis-à-vis de nos
proches et de nos enfants
vraisemblablement la plupart d'entre
nous faisons ça tenir un propos un
propos rassurants ne pas aggraver
l'inquiétude
sauf que on n'attend pas de nos
responsables qu'ils soient paternaliste
maternaliste et ça nous avons du mal
avec ça il ya une pédagogie de
l'incertitude avec laquelle nous avons
du mal en france
est ce que c'est à cause de descartes
est ce que c'est à cause de pasteur est
ce que c'est à cause de claude bernard
ou peut-être les trois tumu est qui
avec eux c'est vrai fermera en fonction
je les noter on a du mal à dire je ne
sais pas je vais vous dire un mois une
fois j'ai décidé de le faire vous avez
oublié cette affaire-là
elle a hanté les nuits pendant presque
six mois c'était la transmission
transfusionnelle du prion les huitième
et neuvième cas de maladie de
creutzfeldt-jakob français avait été
donneurs du sang réguliers et nous
savions qu'il y avait une transmission
possible par les globules rouges pas
possible démontrer ce que nous ne
savions pas
c est ce que les médicaments dérivés du
sang comme les traitements anti mots
philippe pouvait être contaminants et
bien dans la première conférence de
presse que j'ai donnée et contre l'avis
de beaucoup de communicants j'ai dit je
ne sais pas et voilà ce que je vais
mettre en place pour savoir la fère
s'est terminée début 2005 dans une
conférence de presse où j'ai dit
par application du principe de
précaution nous ne ferons rien par
application du principe de précaution
le dossier de presse de cette affaire
est très très facile à retrouver ce à ce
moment là j'ai compris que si au moment
où vous dites je ne sais pas c'est un
moment difficile pour le décideur et
s'éteint et c'est quelque chose qui est
difficile à entendre pour la population
eh bien il faut avoir le courage de le
faire parce qu'après ce que vous faites
quand vous faites ça c'est que vous
établissez une relation de confiance ici
malheureusement il ya eu ce réflexe
habituel de tomber dans un discours
péremptoire au lieu de dire nous n'avons
pas la preuve de l'efficacité des
masques
ce qui est vrai on a dit péremptoirement
ils ne sont pas efficaces voire même ils
sont dangereux je ne sais pas des
spécialistes de des balades et
infectieuses dire que le masque est
dangereuse c'est un peu curieux donc if
bois je laisse souvent je me saoule je
pourrai enfin bon voilà ça va faire
plaisir à mon éditeur
dans ce livre là publié aux puf
j'ai fait le retour d'expérience de mes
grandes décisions
j'ai pas le droit de le faire il est
épuisé donc ça va
et en particulier au moment de l'erika
nous avons eu de la marée noire de
l'erika et de l'impact sanitaire de la
marée noire de l'erika
nous avons eu le même problème et moi
même je suis tombé dedans sur le fait
que le fioul de l'erika était
cancérigène
j'ai commencé par tenir des propos
rassurants et j'ai réalisé qui fit cette
posture là n'était pas la bonne posture
mais c'est et regardez ce qui s'est
passé au moment de lubrizol d'avesnes et
nos revenus h au niveau de la ville on
disait non il n'y a pas de pollution
atmosphérique
la population ne peux pas croire ça donc
voila moi je retiendrai de de ça plus
qu'une question de sang-froid jeu des
vues personnes perdre son sang froid
personnellement mais le fait qu en
situation d'incertitude il faut la dir
il faut l'expliquer à la population il
faut dire ce que l'on met en place pour
la réduire et le politique en
particulier ou un directeur
d'administration centrale ne peut pas
dire des choses que la science ne peut
pas dire sur la recherche parce que je
trouve ça d'abord je voudrais vous faire
remarquer que de façon générale nous
n'avons pas de politique de sécurité
sanitaire nous avons des institutions de
sécurité sanitaire mais notre pays n'est
pas doté d'une véritable politique c'est
quoi une politique c'est une
cartographie des risques
c'est une répartition des
responsabilités c'est des moyens
affectés ces des objectifs à atteindre
c'est des indicateurs nous permettant de
savoir s'ils sont atteints c'est des
mécanismes de pilotage nous n'en avons
pas et ça vaut pour la recherche du coup
nous n'avons pas de programme de
recherche en sécurité sanitaire
comment se fait-il tout le monde sait
les les chauves souris sont à grand
réservoir de virus porter un faux les
cartographier ces virus façon
systématique
voilà un programme de recherche qui
aurait dû être fait on l'aurait trouvé
le coronavirus donc il nous faut un
programme de recherche en sécurité
sanitaire il nous faut une cartographie
des risques de sécurité sanitaire
toutes les grandes entreprises edf ont
pas la nommer pour qui j'ai travaillé en
recherche médicale ont des procédures de
cartographie des risques sans quoi elle
ferait faillite
gérer une entreprise c'est jerry duris
du matin au soir
le patron d'edf a tous les six mois une
actualisation de sa cartographie des
risques qui est discuté en codir et dans
lequel il ya des éléments de sécurité
sanitaire packer évidemment bon et ben
l'état n'a pas ça mérite réflexion
pas de test en phase 3 je sais c'est ce
qui est écrit dans le plan pandémie
parce que l'analyse à ce moment là c'est
que le nombre de malades qui allait se
compter en millions ne le permettait pas
sauf que voilà je te sauf que la
danseuse dans ce cas de figure avec un
nouveau virus qu'on connaissait pas
quatre cinq mille malades par jour ce
qui n'est pas des dizaines de milliers
ou des centaines de milliers comme une
épidémie de grippe peut le faire
là je pense qu'il y avait une adaptation
du plan qu aurait été souhaitable et
qu'il fallait continuer de tracer je le
signale d'ailleurs on parlera peut-être
de mayotte tout à l'heure que les
collègues de la cire de santé publique
france 2 mme ayotte très courageusement
elles sont quatre n'ont jamais arrêté
de faire le traçage des contacts même
quand il quand on est passé en phase iii
et c'est ça qui a permis que l'épidémie
de mayotte soit relativement
relativement maîtrisé si elle ne l'avait
pas fait on serait peut-être dans une
situation de tbh lui yann les
enseignements du strass ils ont ils ont
dit oui il ya eu beaucoup de tirs et on
en a mis dans la loi de 2004
le sénateur giroud dans la loi de 2007
en a on a ajouté on a tiré beaucoup
d'enseignements du strass l'eprus qui
était une proposition du sénateur giroux
et est issu de ça donc oui on a on a
tenu compte et en particulier on a donné
aux préfets des pouvoirs de police
sanitaire pour que ceux qui refusaient
le confinement et bien on est les moyens
de de les contraindre
ce qui n'existait pas en 2003 en 2003 on
a eu des patients qui ont ramené le
strass de 2 du vietnam qui n'ont pas
voulu être confinés et on s'est aperçu
qu'on n'avait pas un instrument
juridique qui nous permettait de le
faire et quand j'ai demandé au préfet de
le faire il a dit je veux bien mais
donnez-moi l'article qui me qui m'assure
de la légalité ma décision et que ce
soit par excès de pouvoir devant les
jurys cela dit j'ai sont dit on l'a pas
l'article nous l'a mis dans la loi de
2004 et dans les lois qui ont suivi
pareil sur la canicule sur la canicule
je vous renvoie à la mission d' enquête
de l'assemblée nationale c'est facile à
trouver je suis encore retourné
récemment j'utilise beaucoup dans mes
enseignements
le rôle que j'ai joué et le fait que
j'ai été le premier à donner l'alerté et
souligné dans ce rapport
pour autant comme je les dis très très
humblement je savais comme
épidémiologistes que les vagues de
chaleur était un risque de mortalité
importante
dix neuf mille morts non ça ne m'a
jamais traversé l'isthme nommé directeur
général de la santé en août 2003 j'ai
reçu une lettre de mission qui me
demandait de préparer des plans de
gestion des situations d'urgence
jeux jeux pour vous dire d'où on partait
beaucoup de mes collaborateurs et de mes
excellents collaborateurs m'ont dit
monsieur le directeur vous vous
fourvoyez le rôle d'une administration
centrale n'est pas de gérer les urgences
nous ne sommes pas le samu bon j'avais
reçu la lettre de mission est le premier
plan évidemment que j'ai développé le
plan canicule
écoutez ce plan a été mis en oeuvre à
plusieurs reprises il a été évalué
il a été amélioré successivement c'est
un plan qui a sauvé énormément de vie
c'est pareil au moment de la canicule
il y avait une erreur de diagnostic
l'hôpital n'était pas assez fort mais 70
% de la mortalité a eu lieu à domicile
par l'hôpital et donc il nous fallait le
plan canicule a été compliqué à faire
parce que ce qu'il nous fallait
c'était une capacité de protection des
personnes fragiles au domicile la
solution qui a été trouvée et de
s'appuyer sur les mairies et les ccas
d'ouvrir un fichier ce pourquoi il a
fallu une loi qui n'existait pas en 2003
permettant aux personnes fragiles de se
faire connaître à la mairie
et quand le plan canicule est déclenché
elles sont appelés deux fois par jour
elle ne répond pas on envoie quelqu'un
voilà
autrement dit c'est à nouveau un travail
de terrain qui fait qu'on peut on peut
sauver des vies là les mairies les élus
locaux ont fait un travail remarquable
en matière de canicule il faut
absolument éviter que les gens arrivent
à l'hôpital s'est renforcée lice
d'urgence
ça n'a pas de sens dans une situation de
canicule il faut intervenir à domicile
quand les personnes arrivant coup de
chaleur aux urgences c'est trop tard
le mortalité va être va être
considérable donc là on a tenu compte
je penses tu de la canicule de 2003 y
est on l'a encore vu l'été dernier la
mortalité observée est très inférieur
alors là pour le coup le modèle entre la
température et la mortalité
il est d'une fiabilité redoutable par
demi degré que vous gagnez en chaleur
vous l'épidémiologie mesure le risque
c'est la relation la plus fiable qui
existent en épidémiologie relations
entre chaleur et mortalité
donc on la connaît maintenant et des
milliers de vies ont été sauvées avec
avec ce dispositif bon ville-hôpital oui
bon là je pense qu'il ya aussi eu on a
entendu des cliniques privées nous dire
qu'elle n'avait pas été suffisamment
sollicités
bon moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui la
distinction entre la ville et l'hôpital
n'a plus de sens tous les médecins
devraient affiliés un centre hospitalier
avec les progrès de l'ambulatoire les
progrès de la télémédecine
cette distinction ville hôpital n'a plus
lieu d'être pour organiser correctement
les soins sauf que regardait les
mécanismes de financement sont
complètement différents je pense qu'il
faut travailler là dessus il faut
arriver à unifier les financements du
secteur hospitalier et de et de la ville
je ne dis pas que j'ai des idées
là-dessus
c'est sûrement très compliqué mais je
pense que c'est un changement c'est un
chantier qu'il faut qu'il faut ouvrir
bon enfin sur l'idh roxy chloroquine bon
vous avez tous noté que c'était un débat
purement franco français voilà je
regrette amèrement que on est vendu dans
les médias y compris par pétition la
prescription de la première fois que je
vois ça des médecins qui demandent à
prescrire par des pétitions
c'est la première fois que je vois ça
moyennant quoi comme on a fait un
battage médiatique avant d'avoir la
preuve
tout le monde s'est rué sur le
médicament et tous les essais
thérapeutiques qui nous aurait donné la
vérité ont été sabotés à part ça quand
on regarde l'ensemble du dossier
on a franchement pas l'impression que
c'est le traitement miracle qu'on nous a
vendu en revanche quand on regarde la
d'exa bêta zone a je pense qu'on a une
piste extrêmement sérieuse de réduction
de la mortalité de l'aco vide
je me pose la question de l'état que
nous qui ne sommes pas médecins nous
soyons dans la situation de méconnaître
les choses mais pour les autorités
sanitaires je suis plus je suis plus
interrogatifs il n'y a jamais eu de
l'exercice en la matière l'exercice
grand terrain vous avez parlé de la
difficulté du commandement et en même
temps de la cartographie des risques
toutes les entreprises qui génèrent un
risque petits ou grands en france y
compris les entreprises agroalimentaires
vous stockez de l'ammoniac vous êtes
soumis à à une cartographie de votre
risque à la fois un risque à l'intérieur
de l'enceinte de l'entreprise moi même
temps à l'extérieur et sur cette
question polémique
jamais il n'y a eu de prise en compte
des choses
or il se trouve que il y a un directeur
général de la santé qui a écrit note
n'était pas directeur général de la
santé il a écrit une note non pas à vous
moi il a écrit une note à celui qui
allait devenir président de la
république et donc je me pose la
question de savoir si qu'est ce qui
s'est passé entre cette note qui date de
2007 et aujourd'hui en 2020 jérôme salle
au mans a écrit aujourd'hui emmanuel
macron 1 a un avantage sur nous tous
c'est d'avoir été alertés avant nous
tous sur cette question et donc moi je
me pose la question de savoir pourquoi
selon vous il n'y a pas eu de réactions
il ya le rôle de l'état d'accord mais a
le rôle des employeurs aussi et le code
du travail est formel la protection de
la santé des travailleurs et de la
responsabilité de l'employeur pas de la
responsabilité de l'état
autrement dit je cherche pas des fossés
qui que ce soit je regarde la loi que
les hôpitaux employeur n'avait pas les
stocks de masques pour protéger leurs
soignants est contraire au code du
travail
ça vaut pour les hôpitaux publics comme
pour les hôpitaux privés code du travail
s'applique dans les deux secteurs faut
pas l'oublier ça ne dispensait pas
l'état de vérifier que la loi était
effective mais il n'y avait pas que
l'état qui avaient des responsabilités
dans ce domaine
le tel que je vois le problème de
l'eprus le problème de l'eprus c'est pas
l'intégrer dans santé publique france
était pas forcément déraisonnable du
tout même la question c'est qu'à ce
moment là ça ne servent pas de variables
de régulation ou de ou de variable
d'ajustement budgétaire et c'est ce que
ça fait donc il fallait sanctuariser ce
cela et avant de couper des postes dans
des organismes de santé publique
il faut réfléchir aux missions que l'on
va perdre c'est ça que j'appelle
pilotage par les objectifs ou pilotage
par eux par les moyens à quoi quoi je
peux répondre
les brise hall pas de morts sans aucun
doute mais alors je vais vous dire une
chose je veux vous rappeler une chose
c'est que les plus il ya eu d'énormes
crise de santé publique ont jamais fait
un mort tchernobyl en france en france
non non attendez
bon là je peux pas me lancer là dedans
mais non non je vous je vous dis non
alors qu'il y en ait eu peut-être
quelques-uns des noms mais deux
évidemment que l'épidémie de cancers de
la thyroïde qu'on a connue n'est pas lié
à tchernobyl ça c'est un consensus
je pense pour pour tout le monde et donc
vous voyez que malgré ça on peut avoir
des crises considérable dans le domaine
de la sécurité sanitaire
alors qu'on a des risques très faible
voire pas de risque du tout bon
qu'est-ce que
notez d'eau pasteur n'a pas de rôle n'a
plus de rôle industriel pasteur met au
point des outils des méthodes brevets tu
fais de la recherche fondamentale de la
recherche appliquée ce pasteur n'a pas
du tout ni commission ni comme
équipement la possibilité de fabriquer
de façon industrielle quoi que ce soit
donc qu'on qu'on est l' expertise
mondiale qui nous permet de mettre tout
de suite au point un test sans aucun
doute
après la question qui se pose c'est
quelle est leur lait industriel pour le
développer et ça ce n'est pas la mission
de l'institut pasteur
alors après je ne suis pas là il ya des
choses vraiment je ne sais pas comment
répond pourquoi tant de rapports ne sont
pas suivies d'effet je ne sais pas il ya
une sorte de ses vrais gelé souvent noté
jeu le jeu voulait dit d'ailleurs tout à
l'heure on pense que comme on a écrit un
texte
on a résolu un problème en vérité le
problème commence au moment où on doit
se préoccuper de la mise en application
des textes on n'a pas ce souci
suffisamment ce souci je connais des
pays comme le canada où on ne peut pas
faire voter une loi si les décrets
d'application ne sont pas présentés au
parlement et nous vous voyez combien de
fois sur des sujets compliqués on
renvoie au décret un décret pris en
conseil d'état précisera etc etc
voyez bien que les dossiers du coup
c'est quand on se met à à toucher du
doigt les problèmes opérationnels posée
par l'application d'une loi c'est c'est
là où tu es en quelque sorte ça
sa motivation là je pense qu'une
amélioration des procédures de
d'adoption des lois serait vraiment
utile parce que comme vous le savez
alors là certainement beaucoup mieux que
moi et vous le sentez dans vos contacts
que vous avez avec la population le fait
qu'on attend de loi non appliquée est un
facteur majeur de perte de confiance de
la population dans les institutions
démocratiques
pendant un certain nombre d'années
j'ai eu à défendre à bercy le budget de
l'état dans le domaine de la santé
alors ce qui m'a toujours frappé c'est
qu'outre ce ministère est équipé en
compétences de très haut niveau
plus que le ministère de la santé mais à
chaque fois on fait face aux mêmes
discours ont écouté ya le budget de la
sécurité sociale
et vous savez qu'il est supérieur au
budget de l'état
donc vous vous calmez dans vos demandes
c'est ça la représentation or le budget
de la sécurité sociale c'est un budget
de soins
voilà donc c'est pas seulement un
problème culturel
c'est un problème aussi structurelles
dans l'âme dans dans la place qu'on
donne à la prévention dans dans notre
pays
j'entends j'entends ce que vous dites
sur la vraiment il faut je ne sais
franchement très honnêtement je ne sais
pas si j'avais été en situation de
décision
ce que j'aurais fait je vous le dis très
honnêtement confiné tout le monde ou
confinés les trois régions où il y avait
des tensions hospitalières
ce que je note c'est un problème de
cohérence du discours soit on dit nous
voulons complètement stoppé la
circulation virale en france il est
logique de confiner tout le monde soit
on dit là le but de confinement et
d'éviter l'effondrement hospitalier la
jeudi la décision n'était pas cohérente
avec ce but je pense rendre service je
ne critique pas je pense rendre service
en soulignant qu' il ya un point de
cohérence du discours
c'est à dire contre l'objectif que l'on
vise est le moyen que l'on met en oeuvre
il faut s'assurer de la cohérence
si je le sais ça que j'ai dit en
introduction
si on dit que l'objectif du confinement
et d'éviter la surtension hospitalière
alors dans 24 des 27 régions
il n'était pas non qu'est-ce que je
réponde enfin qu'apporte fatigué dans
toutes les régions sauf 3 il ne
s'imposait pas nécessairement maintenant
sur le principe de précaution voilà
j'étais je me souviens très bien de la
note que j'ai faite au ministre pour
dire que je soutenais ce qui était écrit
dans la charte de l'environnement que je
souhaitais clos beneath de la santé soit
soit en accord avec sa skiff c'est ce
qui fut le cas mais ce principe de
précaution il faut pas il ne doit pas
être brandie comme un slogan c'est un
principe qui quand même un site c'est
écrit comme ça à mettre en oeuvre une
balance bénéfices risques
or on pouvait penser qu'ils compris en
termes de santé publique
le confinement peut avoir des effets
indésirables
je ne me prononce pas là-dessus mais je
vous dis
rendez vous l'année prochaine comme nous
aurons un bilan de l'ensemble de la
mortalité dans notre pays de ses causes
y compris de la mortalité que des
collègues commencent à me signaler
neurovasculaire cardiovasculaires parce
que les gens ne se sont pas fait soigner
pendant le confinement
on verra de quel côté est et le principe
de précaution donc je dis juste que si
on accepte l'idée du principe de
précaution ce que je fais volontiers
évidemment comme avocat de la santé il
n'était pas forcément évident que
c'était de ce côté là que l'avalanche
devait pencher ce que je crois aussi
c'est que dans ces situations très
incertaine
on n'est pas obligé de prendre des
décisions général et généralisé tout de
suite on peut avancer pas à pas
le confinement de trois régions
s'imposait début marc pas début mars mi
mars
sans aucun doute faute que les tests etc
nous est permis d'avoir une autre une
autre stratégie pour le reste on pouvait
laisser l'activité économique se
développe et qui tu as si votre crainte
dans le tarn étaient justifiées voir que
on maîtrisait pas la circulation virale
on aurait pu étendre à ce moment là le
raisonnement mais ça c'est ça que je
veux dire quand
quand je dis qu'il faut un mélange de
jacobins en gironde 1 c'est que on est
via cette uniformisation si c'est beau
pour les uns ça doit être bon pour tout
le monde
je pense qu'en tout cas c'est pareil
pour le déconfinement certaines régions
pouvaient déconfit n'est plus vite que
d'autres
et d'ailleurs on aurait appris elle ça
nous aurait permis d'apprendre
voilà et sa culturellement nous avons dû
main quant aux conséquences économiques
alors écoutez je ne suis pas économiste
mais je pense
voilà vous regarderez ça certainement
mieux que moi il me semble avoir vu que
en europe c'est en france que les
conséquences économiques vont être les
pires et que le pib allemand ne chutera
pas autant que le autant que le nôtre
mais peut-être peut-être je me trompe
c'est donc un constat sévère que william
dab a livré devant les députés vis-à-vis
des autorités
il a notamment insisté sur les leçons à
tirer de la crise et sur le besoin
urgent d'investir dans la prévention et
dans les politiques de sécurité
sanitaire cette audition comme toutes
celles de la commission denquête est à
retrouver sur notre site
lcp point fr